notre panel politique ce soir avec ses
fait grandement à la question gay et
stéphanie chouinard bonsoir à vous trois
bonsoir mon personne va se réjouir qu'on
parle de covin encore une fois ma ronde
de paul choix d'autant plus qu'il est
respectueux a confirmé aujourd'hui qu'on
était bel et bien plongé dans la sixième
vague d'ailleurs ça se voit depuis une
semaine les chiffres ont bien montré aux
décors hausse des hospitalisations même
si les cas sont sous représentées on
voit une tendance eidos peu étonnant
c'est que pas plus tard que dimanche le
directeur de la santé publique par
intérim monsieur boillon ne voulait pas
confirmé qu'on était dans une sixième
bague donc quelques jours plus tard on
confirmait là qu'est ce que ça vous
étonne
plus ou moins sous le niveau de ratio
arodaky à la première vague avait pris
beaucoup de temps à confirmer la
deuxième on est au low très prudent à la
du côté de la santé publique on se
demande si c'est une petit soubresaut
une vaguelette ça prend toujours
quelques jours avant que l'évidence
s'impose et qu'on confirme qui est bel
et bien une sixième bague earth est
venue de liens et spéculent aujourd'hui
non pas de la direction rire général de
la santé publique donc pas du côté de
boileau que c'est venu mais on a
confirmé ce qu'on santos la réalité on
oui les chiffres de ceux qui ont accepté
spéciales y a que 10 % de la population
qui ont accès mais je pense que vous
avez autant d'amis de famille des
collègues de moi qui sont touchés depuis
maintenant à peu près une semaine du
jour là mais c'était assez clair qu'on
était dans ce début de sixième bague le
wep les gens région particulièrement
parle beaucoup on sait que sa frappe
très très fort dans le bas saint laurent
entre autres en gaspésie sur la
côte-nord aussi à tel point que les
santé publique locale d'ailleurs
rappelle les mesures et dire aux gens
restés prudents le cpo terminé au
contraire cette vague l'eau se fait
sentir mais ça se sentir jusqu'à
l'assemblée nationale vous l'avez vu
aujourd'hui là on est rendu à quoi la au
delà de sept élus de la cac les élus de
l'opposition en toute hâte une dizaine
actuellement qui sont absents parce
qu'ils ont la coved monsieur legault
savent aussi tirer même un peu on le
reverra probablement pas avant la
semaine prochaine il a annulé encore des
activités cette semaine
stéphanie grave hand on voit même la
chaîne de commandement quand vous avez
le premier ministre est absent parce
qu'elle a co buhl aujourd'hui on apprend
que la vice-première ministre aussi est
absente parce que l'aco vide ça
fragilise quand même un petit peu la
chaîne de commande le
oui bon c'est sûr mais ces gens ne sont
pas vivre dans la même société que tout
le monde
ils ont pour faire attention je présume
que ils sont pas immunisés même s'ils
ont eu à l'est le vaccin est comme eux
et qu'ils ont suivi les règles
sanitaires trouve le croire et on le
voit partout l'alec le disais dans les
universités dans les écoles dans les
milieux de travail
beaucoup de gens sont absents beaucoup
de gens ou non l'accord vide et puis oui
on s'en doutait bien qu'on aura une
sixième vague le docteur boileau parler
de ce qu'on était en route toulouse le
week-end dernier voilà on est vraiment
bien embarqué dans l'autobus son centre
en force et honnêtement la cinquième
vague a été tellement difficile sur le
moral on espérait que ça prendra un peu
plus de temps avant que la prochaine
vague viennent mais non malheureusement
donc il va falloir me faire face on n'a
pas le choix et puis peut-être que
malheureusement il ya certaines mesures
qui qu'on a laissé tomber ou qu'on avait
on avait laissé espérer que ça que ça
disparaître l eau comme le port du
masque à la mi avril
j'ai bien peur que l'on doive garder
soit plus longtemps ainsi les choses
persiste et sur les impacts sur
l'assemblée nationale sur le bon
fonctionnement des travaux voici là
dessus sinon je n'ai barrett
ont fait des recommandations de la santé
publique et pour les travaux
parlementaires en séance jusqu'à
contrôleurs et des deux côtés de la
chambre comme dans l'ensemble de la
population
il ya des gens qui ap ap la corée des
dons qui s'isole pour la carrière des
kirghizes
ses fans et chine a maintenant plus que
stéphanie grammond disait à la société
civile les élus c'est le même mot
finalement donc ils sont pas immunisées
contre lacko vide reste que quand même
on a dû reporter un peu plus tard une
commission parlementaire cette semaine
qui a été rendue dans une phase de
détails d'un projet de loi sur la loi de
l'assurance automobile et est ce que ça
quand même des impacts et l'inesss
l'organisme qui produit d appréciation
de ce qui s'en vient dans le futur
comment souci a sonné la sonnette
d'alarmé en disant attention là on
prévoit des hausses d'hospitalisation ça
pourrait s'accélérer il n'y a pas de
mesures qui ont été annoncées on n'a
rien resserré pour l'instant à votre
avis est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on répète
les mêmes erreurs qu'avec les autres
vagues c'est à dire qu ont réagi trop
tard
et on réagit peut-être trop tard mais
aussi on a des confiné peut-être trouvé
temps on est actuellement dans une
situation où bon on a un début de vagues
qui ressemble énormément la cinquième
vague mais en termes d'activité de la
société civile on est pas du tout là où
on était au début de la cinquième vague
on a des lieux publics où il ya presque
plus de différenciation sociale s'il y
en a du tout on est de retour à 100%
dans les commerces en ontario les
masques ne sont plus obligatoires dans
les lieux publics non plus et on parle
dans les institutions notamment pour
secondaires et les hôpitaux de faire
tomber le monde hommes accidents laa
partir du 1er mai donc on n'a pas les
conditions gagnantes pour pour disons
s'assurer que cette nouvelle vague la
haine ne prennent pas des proportions
qui sont les pires parmi les différents
scénarios qui nous sont présentés lors
de la cinquième vague alec on s'en
rappelle le gouvernement avait réagi
réagir si durement parce qu'on est même
retournée dans un grand confinement mais
peut-être avec un certain délai en fait
c'est ce que des observateurs lui avait
reproché dans quelle situation se
retrouve actuellement un gouvernement
après toutes ces manifestations de
camionneurs de gens qui dénoncent ce
camp pouvait plus le des mesures
sanitaires après qu'on voit aussi le
pass conservateurs du québec qui est en
hausse dans les sondages et qui mise
justement sur ce mécontentement sur les
mesures sanitaires c'est gouvernement
doit prendre de nouvelles mesures ainsi
ça s'accélère ex empire la situation ça
veut mettre la caq tome est dans une
situation difficile
oui absolument mais faudrait que ça
s'empire vraiment beaucoup pour qu'on
revienne à ce qu'on avait connu d'abord
parce qu'on est pour même point on a
trois millions de québécois qui ont été
infectés par lettre par la cinquième
vague il y en a encore qui l'ont été
dans les dernières semaines derniers
mois les troisièmes doses sont beaucoup
plus avancé qu'elle ne l'était en
décembre on n'avait pas de troisième de
personnes à mettre sous presse là on a
quand même la moitié des québécois
surtout surtout ceux qui sont les plus
et plus ariste les plus de 60 ans ont
été vaccinés plus de 85% il ya quand
même donc des différences
épidémiologique assez importantes dont 3
pas besoin de ramener le couvre-feu ne
devraient pas être obligés de ramener
des restrictions dans les commerces on
devrait avoir une protection immunitaire
suffisante pour traverser que ça
répondait qu'il va y avoir du coeur a
pas de hausse de spécialisation et
encore des gens pour vacciner ya encore
des gens vulnérables et des gens qui
vont avoir besoin question c'est ce que
le réseau capable de le supporter
christian dubé disait cette semaine on
est capable on a une marge de manoeuvre
pendant encore plusieurs semaines pour
être capable de supporter cette hausse
là donc moi je pense que c'est très
prématuré de dire est ce qu on va être
obligé de revenir on n'est pas obligé de
penser à chaque vague comme les vagues
précédent une évolution dans l'épidémie
dans la dans le virus dans la manière
dont il se transmet pee wee
politiquement on est en année où c'est
plus compliqué c'est effectivement plus
compliqué donc le gouvernement va
vraiment prendre son temps avant de voir
son a besoin de quelque chose de plus
sévère mais oui le port du masque à la
mi avril ça me paraît un peu pour
l'éviter tête est ce que le match voir
revenir dans les écoles côté jean de
petites mesures très simples à mettre en
place font une grosse différence mais
ferme et les restaurants fermés les
commerces - nettement le jour puis sow
le même à moyen terme je pense oui
monsieur monsieur dubé bull didier bence
la marge de manoeuvre dans les hôpitaux
même si lyn et ce monde qu'il va avoir
une hausse des hospitalisations
stéphanie grammond là dessus monsieur
dubé d'ailleurs il a renouvelé les
primes kovy dans les extensions n'est
finalement pas ce que pour que ça
fonctionne dans les hôpitaux ça prend du
personnel nécessaire mais nous oui puis
on voit que les absences sont en forte
hausse là depuis depuis quelques jours
depuis une semaine donc les effectifs ne
sont pas là on a besoin de monde alors
oui les primes ccc de retour est tant
mieux et puis bon il faudra faire ce
qu'il faut pour traiter les gens parce
que ce sont les plus vulnérables les
personnes âgées qui vont évidemment et
copie on le sait bien c'est vraiment
exponentielle les risques et de respect
de spécialisation pour les plus jeunes
sont quand même relativement faible mais
plus on peut longuement pas en danger
puis çà çà çà double pratiquement à
chaque estrade de 5 ans donc les gens
qui sont qui sont à risque ce sont ces
genres il faut faire attention et je
pense que c'est la responsabilité de
chacun dans la société
d'être plus d'un et plus de garder le
maximum de mesures sanitaires pour que
ces gens là ne soit pas ne soit pas les
migrants perdant oui et pour le kurde et
le plus âgé les 80 ans et plus à 4e 12
le fait déjà commencé cette semaine
parlons de l'autre sujet qui fait
énormément réagir cette controverse dans
laquelle nage actuellement l'université
laval parce qu'elle a lancé un appel de
candidatures pour une chaire de
recherche mais a affirmé dans son appel
de candidatures qu'on ne retient que
ceux qui font partie d'un des quatre
groupes de minorités qui se détaille
comme suit pour montrer un tableau à nos
téléspectateurs alors il faut faire
parce qu'ils soient du groupe des femmes
des membres de minorités visibles et
ethniques être autochtone ou encore être
une personne avec un handicap à
condition bien sûr d'avoir les
compétences requises c'est largement
dénoncée par la classe politique on
écoute des réactions on veut avoir plus
on veut plus de femmes ne veut plus de
demande et minutes était visée mais de
discriminer pour combattre la
discrimination je pense une fausse bonne
idée
je suis en faveur fait qu'on doit avoir
une meilleure représentativité cas aucun
doute dans ma tête aucun doute mais
d'aller de là à les exclure du monde
sur cette base là je pense pas qu'on va
dans la bonne direction je pense qu'on
va trop loin j'ai complètement
inacceptable au lieu d'avoir un système
juste basée sur le mérite de chacun peu
importe notre différence on se retrouve
dans un système où on n'empêche certains
candidats
avec un certain profil de pouvoir être
évalué au mérite de leurs compétences et
de leurs idées
alors finalement ceux qui peuvent pas
postuler façon générale si on peut faire
un petit portrait rapide c'est pas mal
un homme blanc stéphanie chouinard est
ce que c'est de la discrimination à vos
yeux
le gouvernement fédéral fonctionne de
cette façon là avec tout les chaires de
recherche du canada et la façon dont ça
fonctionne je pense que c'est important
de l'expliquer c'est que lorsqu'il ya
l'octroi d'une chaire de recherche à une
institution en particulier en
l'occurrence ici l'université laval le
gouvernement fédéral va regarder qui
d'autre à l'intérieur de l'institution a
déjà des chaires de recherche du canada
et sillonne sur présentation de certains
groupes ce qu'on constate ici c'est qu'à
l'université laval une
sur-représentation parmi le corps
professoral d'hommes blancs qui sont des
récipiendaires des chaires de recherche
du canada et on demande donc à
l'université laval de tenter de trouver
un équilibre et il se crée connu dans le
milieu universitaire que les femmes et
les personnes racialisée les personnes
avec des handicaps sont sous produits ou
dans le milieu universitaire donc pas
seulement pour des chars de recherche et
pour aussi pour la titularisation par
exemple et donc il faut comprendre que
cette décision-là à bien dans un
contexte qui est beaucoup plus large
après on peut parler de ce que c'est la
discrimination positive
évidemment il ya des contre arguments
qui viennent avec ce type ce type de
décision là mais c'est pas une décision
qui était présent lorsque loupé c'est
pas non plus une décision qui a été
prise seulement par ce département lundi
par l'université laval dans un vacuum
bon s'intéressant d'élargir le débat
effectivement de voir un petit peu plus
largement mais je vais compléter mon
tour de table elle est que vous en
pensez quoi est-ce que vous êtes à
l'aise avec ce concept là
enfin comble mais oui mais ça c'est rien
tu postules et maintenant je n'aurais
pas pu
je pense que le fait de base uniquement
sur le mérite comme le dit paul st
pierre plamondon historiquement
avantages et l'homme blanc en question
donc ce système là parce que l'on dit
bien conscient parce que là toutes
sortes de préjugés non affirmé ont
favorisé une certaine
représentation de l'homme blanc autant
dans les chaires de recherche que dans
l'épreuve les postes de professeurs et
que donc combattre souhaite une bonne
chose il faut le faire d'ailleurs
l'université laval une politique qui a
compétence égale si quelqu'un postule
sur une chaire de recherche on va
choisir la personne représentant une
minorité autochtone première nation
noire et c'est donc à compétences égales
on favorise déjà les minorités pour être
capable de leur résister mais c'est pas
comme ça l'appel de candidatures libéré
voilà des sujets qui est un groupe qui
ne peut pas du tout postuler nick on ne
sait pas si en fait même dans les autres
groupes quelque chose d'intéressant vont
être amenées sur la table s'il va y
avoir des candidatures intéressantes on
dit d'emblée on ne veut pas un certain
groupe la société pour ce type de
recherche le en biologie dans ce cas ci
ça m'apparaît allé assez loin quand même
dans la discrimination positive qu'ont
prague et des réticences en 10 ans on
est vraiment rendu là on peut même pas
trier là parmi tout ce qu'on a fait on
décide que certaines personnes peuvent
même pas faire valoir leurs compétences
dans ce qui choque un peu les gens on
pourrait au moins par ce comité car
ensuite choisir si effectivement on peut
être plus représentatif de la barre est
complètement group la société je peux
comprendre que ça je suis comme bien des
séries fisc devrait seulement seulement
30 secondes 3 30 rock est bon j'ai eu
pendant
parce que je l'entends sevani g en
hausse ils adoptent qu'on ait le temps
de l'écrit alors oui c'est un exemple
c'est quoi mais oui et puis sachez que
délicat faut prendre le temps c'est un
sujet qui très délicat qu'il faut il
faut manipuler avec soin je suis assez
d'accord mecs que avec ceux de mes
collègues viennent de dire je pense que
c'était pas habile de fermer la porte
carrément honey 2 blanc est de 10 ans
mais en même temps je crois que et puis
si je peut élargir le débat encore plus
à l'extérieur des universités dans les
entreprises dans les conseils
d'administration une fraction minuscule
de femmes et ça ça augmente un petit peu
mais très très très lentement donc si on
ne prend pas de mesures pour essayer
d'accélérer le changement
malheureusement on va être encore
largement minoritaire dans 5 ans 10 ans
20 ans 30 ans peu importe donc oui je
pense que c'est logique de dire essayons
de trouver des façons de
faire en sorte que les femmes que les
gens des communautés culturelles
les autochtones akyé terrain tout ce
beau monde là un plus à voir aussi percé
le placent le plafond de verre et ça ça
peut vouloir dire travailler en amont
sur le sur le bassin de candidats de
dire à des femmes à des autochtones à
dire peu importe on va vous prendre vos
fins en sorte que vous que vous puissiez
montée jusqu'au sommet et ça peut
vouloir aussi dire de mettre des toutes
sortes de cocteau le terme fait peur
mais dans certains cas d'essayer
d'arriver à une
représentation qui est meilleur qui est
plus paritaires et oui c'est vrai que
dans certains cas ça peut ça peu
désavantagés à compétences égales la
peine l'homme blanc mais en même temps
comment comme on n'arrivera pas été plus
rapidement si on prend pas ces mesures
là oui mais même pour une question
d'équité un homme blanc par exemple qui
est qui voyaient dans cette candidature
cet appel de candidatures sa chance en
fin d'avoir sa chaire de recherche par
exemple pourrait dire écoutez je suis
homo je suis victime d'un préjudice je
pourrais je pourrais poursuivre je
pourrais évoquer les chattes parce que
j'ai moins de droits dans ce contexte
fille s'est fait librement mais c'est
pour ce que je dis ça je crois que ça va
trop loin il faut quand même donner la
chance à tout le monde de faire valoir
son
cv et puis bon aussi on s'entend que il
ya pas une femme qui voudrait être nommé
dans un poste parce que elle est une
femme en guinée on veut évidemment tout
le monde d'être nommé parce qu'on a les
compétences et qu'on dit on sentiments
et à la bonne personne au bon endroit
donc ça je crois que tout se doit entrer
dans la balance mais oui on doit donner
la chance à tous les coureurs oui ses
fans et chouinard dernier mot là dessus
parce qu'on voit vraiment le fond une
grosse controverse comme on arrive à
apaiser un peu
et ça serait passé pour l'université
laval de revoir son appel à candidatures
évidemment ça sera au département oui et
au comité de sélection a à prendre la
décision à la fin de la journée donc la
balle est dans leur camp finalement
voilà que là mais alex stéphanie et
stéphanie merci beaucoup pour le panel
de ce soir
au revoir merci pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit